So now we've talked about how the cache works for
updating normal files from the cache. Now the whole app
cache system is actually very complex. It's a very complex
algorithm that the browser goes through to get files out of
the cache, figure out whether it should update the cache,
check the different sections in the file. We do want to
talk briefly about the network section for files that always
need to be loaded from the network, so let's go take
a look at that. The network section was supposed
to make it easier to build applications that were
occasionally online, but it turns out that's pretty hard
to do. As we talked about before, it's hard to
answer the question definitively if you're online or offline.
One common thing to do is in the network section
at the bottom to put a star, or even
just to only have a star here. This basically means
anything that anything we haven't specified already further up in
the application cache in the cache section, you should just
go to the network for. This is actually isn't a
great thing to do. If you have any blocking resources
in your file, or in your application that haven't been
listed in the cache file, it's going to sit there and
wait until it times out. So what you should really
do, is develop without that network star. Even if you add
it later. That way, your cache updates in the
console will actually show you if you're missing files.